good evening welcome to New Orleans I
don't know if you knew this but you are
sitting within 15 minutes of one of the
largest rivers in the world the
Mississippi River Old Man River Big
Muddy and it goes as far north as the
state of Minnesota as far east as the
state of New York as far west as Montana
and a hundred miles from here
River miles it empties its freshwater
and sediments into the Gulf of Mexico
that's the end of geography 101 now
we're going to go to what is in that
water
besides the sediment there are dissolved
molecules nitrogen and phosphorus and
those through a biological process lead
to the formation of areas called dead
zones now dead zone is a quite ominous
word if you're a fish or a crab even a
little worm in the sediments which means
that there's not enough oxygen for those
animals to survive so how does this
happen
the nitrogen and the phosphorus
stimulate the growth of microscopic
plants called phytoplankton and small
animals called zooplankton eat the
phytoplankton small fish eat the
zooplankton large fish eat the small
fish and it goes on up into the food web
the problem is that there's just too
much nitrogen and phosphorous right now
too much phytoplankton falling to the
bottom and decomposed by bacteria that
use up the oxygen that's the biology
now you can't see it from the surface of
the water you can't see it in satellite
images so how do we know it's there well
a trawler can tell you when she puts her
net over the side and drags for 20
minutes and comes up empty that she
knows she's in the dead zone and she has
to go somewhere else but where else do
you go if this area is 8,000 square
miles big about the size of the state of
New Jersey
well you don't either make a decision to
go further without much economic return
or go back to the dock as a scientist I
have access to high-tech equipment that
we can put over the side of the research
vessel and it measures oxygen and many
more things
we start at the Mississippi River we
crisscross the Gulf of Mexico
all the way to Texas and even I sneak
into Texas every now and then and test
their waters and you can tell by the the
bottom oxygen you can draw a map of
everything that's less than 2 which is
the magic number for when the fish start
to leave the area
I also dive in this dead zone we have
oxygen meters that we have to deploy
offshore that tell us continuous
measurements of low oxygen or high
oxygen and when you get into the water
there's a lot of fish tons of fish all
kinds of fish including my buddy here
the Barracuda that I saw one day
everybody else
swam this way and I went this way with
my camera so and then down at 30 feet
you start to see fewer fish and then you
get to the bottom and you don't see any
fish there's no life on the platform
there's no life swimming around and you
know you're in the dead zone so what's
the connection between the middle of the
United States and the Gulf of Mexico
well most of the watershed is farmland
and
in particular corn soybean rotation the
nitrogen that is put in fertilizers and
the phosphorous goes on the land and
drains off into the Mississippi River
and ends up in the Gulf of Mexico
there's three times more nitrogen in the
water in the Mississippi now than there
was in the 1950s three times and
phosphorus has doubled and what that
means is more phytoplankton and more
sinking cells and lower oxygen this is
not a natural feature of the Gulf it's
been caused by human activities the
landscape is not what it used to be it
used to be prairies and forests and
prairie potholes and duck areas and all
kinds of stuff but not anymore it's it's
broke crops and there are ways that we
can address this type of agriculture by
using less fertilizer maybe precision
fertilizing and trying some sustainable
agriculture such as perennial wheat
grass which has much longer rates than
the six inches of a corn plant that can
keep the nitrogen on the soil and keep
the soil from running off and how do we
convince our neighbors to the north
maybe a thousand miles away or more that
their activities are causing problems
with water quality in the Gulf of Mexico
first of all we can take them to their
own backyard if you want to go swimming
in Wisconsin in the summer in your
favorite watering hole you might find
something like this which looks like
spilled green paint and smells like it
growing on the surface of the water this
is a toxic blue-green algal bloom and it
is not good for you
similarly in like Erie a couple of
summers ago there was hundreds of miles
of this blue-green algae in the city of
Toledo Ohio
couldn't use it for their drinking water
for several days on end and if you watch
the news you know that lots of
communities are having trouble with
drinking water I'm a scientist I don't
know if you could tell that but you know
and I do solid science I published my
results my colleagues read them I get
citations of my work but I truly believe
that as a scientist using mostly federal
funds to do the research I owe it to the
public to agency heads and congressional
people to share my knowledge with them
so they can use it hopefully to make
better decisions about our environmental
policy thank you
one of the ways that I was able to do
this is I brought in the media and Joby
Warwick from the Washington Post put
this picture in an article on the front
page
Sunday morning two inches above the fold
that's a big deal and Senator John
Breaux from Louisiana said oh my gosh
that's what they think the Gulf of
Mexico looks like and I said well you
know there's the proof and we've got to
do something about it at the same time
senator Olympia Snowe from Maine was
having trouble with harmful algal blooms
in the Gulf of Maine they join forces it
was bipartisan and invited me to give
congressional testimony I said all I've
done is chase crabs around South Texas I
don't know how to do that but I did it
and eventually the bill passed and it
was called yeah yeah it was called the
harmful algal bloom and hypoxia research
and Control Act of 1998 which is
which is why we call it the snow bro
bill so the other thing is that we had a
conference in 2001 that was put on by
the National Academy of Sciences that
looked at fertilizers nitrogen and poor
water quality our plenary speaker was
the former governor of the state of New
Jersey
and she and no there was no thinking she
wasn't serious when she peered at the
audience and I thought surely she's
looking at me you know I'm really tired
of this thing being called New Jersey
pick another state any state I just
don't want to hear it anymore but she
was able to move the action plan across
President George George HW Bush's desk
so that we had environmental goals and
that we were working to solve them the
Midwest does not feed the world it feeds
a lot of chickens hogs cattle and it
generates ethanol to put into our
gasoline which is regulated by federal
policy we can do better than this we
need to make decisions that make us less
consumptive and reduce our reliance on
nitrogen it's like a carbon footprint
but you can reduce your nitrogen
footprint I do it by not eating much
meat
I still like a little every now and then
not using corn oil driving a car that I
can put non ethanol gas in and get
better gas mileage just things like that
that can make a difference so I'm
challenging not just you but I challenge
a lot of people especially in the
Midwest think about how you're treating
your land and how you can make a
difference so my steps are very small
steps to change the type of agriculture
in the u.s. is going to be many big
steps and it's going to take political
and social will for that to happen but
we can do it I strongly believe we can
translate the science
Brigit to policy and make a difference
in our environment we all want a clean
environment and we can work together to
do this so that we no longer have these
dead zones in the Gulf of Mexico thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]